we have a criminal justice system today  that it's not only broken it is racist  got more people in jail than any other  country on earth including China one of  the reasons for that is a horrific war  on drugs so I do believe that on day one  we will change the federal controlled  substance act which if you can believe  it  now equates heroin with marijuana that's  insane  we're going to take marijuana out of  that and effectively legalize marijuana  in every state in the country what we  are also going to do is move to expunge  the records of those people who arrested  for possession of marijuana and I'll  tell you what else we're going to do  we're gonna provide help to the African  American Latino Native American  community to start businesses to sell  legal marijuana rather than let a few  corporations control the legalized  marijuana market  you